we'll have a cup here with some maple
syrup
cheers we should should probably show
you you just down that whole thing no no
no i'm gonna sip it i'm gonna sip it you
know but by all means
it's really good right
yeah yeah
that is uh maple syrup yeah
that's a perfect july day
from canada in a bottle yeah
so you're uh on a totally uh
on a total tangent you are known for
appreciating food in all kinds of ways
but one of the things you're known for
is pancakes
that is uh yeah that's gone into a crazy
place in the sport but yeah like where
did that originate
so
um
where that originated when it went from
like your actual love for pancakes to
the meme
yeah so so i think what happened was uh
um so
i had a match with michael todd
big match uh michael
great champion
um he's another guy who's you know he's
never gonna get off the horse uh you
know he's uh jesus
his elbow is a complete disaster
um
probably one of the most loved and hated
guys in the sport right now um
is it because of the king's move
yeah the king's move brings him a lot of
hate um not from me not from a lot of
people but um
a lot of observers have a big problem
with the king's move
what's wrong with being a little bit
controversial that's fun
you know i get so passionate about it i
get so angry you know because there's a
saying like oh can you beat him in a
hook can you be man
win yeah win that's all that matters
that's it just win and don't talk to me
about anything else
if you can win with style win will stop
but don't talk to me about anything but
winning other it's that's the priority
so you had this match with mike taj yeah
so
i was in a terrible place
um
i guess was i get so screwed up with
years it's 20 22 now right no it's 20
30. what are you talking about yeah
that's right i think it is actually 20
30. we're way ahead of schedule yeah oh
man that's right so when was this this
is like a decade ago or no no this is uh
like a year and a bit ago so this is
very recent very recent yeah
so
i got really sick
yeah this is the match right okay
awesome match uh
so this is this match is for the legacy
hammer
so we invented this thing called the
legacy hammer and michael took it from
me and i think 2018
and then kovid shut everything down and
michael went overseas to try and set up
because at that time nor michael was a
north american champion
he beat me and
he went to dubai and he organized this
great big match with lavonne
and the whole thing fell apart
organizers leagues wouldn't let it
happen but
there was still an ability to have a
match of significance happen so
michael's like who do you want and like
let's give devin a rematch and i'm like
yes and i was really sick at the time
uh i had dvt
i had pulmonary embolism i was
mentally in a terrible place
and i got offered the match and i just
totally turned my life around
and
i committed
really hard yeah and uh what happened in
this match by the way
oh i just totally destroyed him
yeah i just beat the piss out of him
yeah
um
michael's a good friend of mine
but uh yeah there's a lot of camaraderie
yeah and you guys talked afterwards
but we fight like like brothers you know
like so we let each other really fight
hard against each other
but so i was
i knew i mean strength and mass they go
hand in hand
and
i committed to just getting as big and
as strong as i could and literally i was
eating pancakes every day
bacon pancakes every sloppy bit of
garbage food i could eat i was trying to
eat healthy also but if there was
garbage food i'd eat it what do you mean
bacon and pancakes isn't healthy what
are you talking about exactly ah people
should go watch there's a video where
you make like the
the canadian
meal of uh bacon with some bacon cooking
tips water that was interesting yeah and
then um and then obviously pancakes and
maple syrup all over the whole thing
yeah
yeah you're making me very hungry i i've
caused more diabetes than uh you know
probably gonna get in trouble karmically
for
making the world obese you should
probably write a like like a book the
pancake diet yeah devon yep i think i
will do that one day
you